anna what's going on well my husband and
i have been married
for three years okay we have a
three-month-old little boy
so y'all are in it right we're in it and
adoring it loving it it's amazing i love
being a mom
ah so cool how long did y'all date
before you got married
a year okay okay so this is all real
fast huh
this is all real fast hey hi i love you
guys good to meet you let's get married
let's have a kid all right so you're in
it so now what
now what's going on yes so we might have
rushed a few things in getting married
in the word yeah when you
examine and go over goals in life and
different things
um it sounds a little bit different
before marriage than when you're putting
it into practice
yep seeing it lived out yes yes yes um
so i i've followed dave ramsey's plan
for a long time i'm debt-free i've
saved up an emergency fund and
he is he's a wonderful guy um has
struggled
with alcohol addiction issues okay um
sometimes that's still in the present um
and he is also horrible with money
okay his financial plan is give me
whatever's left over
okay and um
and then i make up whatever difference
and he doesn't
he doesn't have money saved i know that
in a marriage you're supposed to join
bank accounts and those types of things
but there's not enough
trust to to give that over yet
on my side because i've been very
responsible and
i got a lot of reward and value from
working hard to get through dave's
program and so i can see from the other
side how valuable it is and i would love
for him to be able
to possess that and know that and work
hard
but at the same time we're married and
supposed to be working together
and i don't i don't know how to do that
um yeah so
yeah and i just get left with everything
yeah you're married to an addict
okay and um
here's the here's the the heartbreaking
dance y'all
are in um addiction is a connection
disorder okay
people get used substances or work
or sex or whatever to
numb the fact that they're disconnected
from other people okay
and people have to protect themselves
from people who are addicts
because they're not reliable they're not
safe they aren't
um they don't show up they don't um
follow through et cetera
and so then people have to protect them
and what that means in a relationship is
i gotta unplug a little bit
sometimes a lot which then leads to more
addiction and then you see how the dance
goes right correct
at the end of the day none of this works
unless your husband chooses to get clean
correct and he he works on it and
he was clean before we got married and
then relapsed a few months into it
and has gone through a few of those
cycles
part of it was my misunderstanding i
thought hey you get in a healthy
environment
and you get healthier but that's not the
case with addiction
and it's heartbreaking but yeah um he
doesn't he's not getting the help
that he needs no matter what anyone
around him says
so i know it's up to him i can't do it
our son can't do it
right it's up to him and so i'm gonna
tell you to protect yourself and protect
your finances
and protect that little baby love love
love your husband
right and the what you need to do is
make sure you don't keep secrets okay
i want you to encourage him to get well
and to get healthy
and to create an environment for him
where that's okay for him like you know
what i mean like not making fun of him
and not getting onto him i know you
wouldn't i'm speaking
more to people who are listening right
now and not beating him up
and tell him what a loser he is and all
that kind of stuff that doesn't help
an addict um but at the same time yeah
unfettered access to your checking
account and things like that will create
more and more mess down the road he's
going to have to decide to get clean
yes so how do you how do you um like if
he has an emergency come up
do i just leave him on his own when he
hasn't been financially responsible
to no yeah you're his wife
and so you've got to plan for
contingencies right
um so at the same time i mean this is
just a messy situation for you
okay it is um yeah you if he's
give me an example of a messy sticky
situation he's gonna get himself into
um he had back pain and needed an
epidural which cost a thousand dollars
he does real estate photography and
crashed his drone that sixteen hundred
dollars
and i didn't cover those things because
i just didn't want to because i've
covered a lot of other stuff
and then like um if he loses a job or
um when his back went out i just got
left with all the bills
right which all right so
it's hard so here
here's where it's hard is you've got a
pronoun problem and the pronoun problem
is
his job his health his
insurance his money and y'all are
married this is y'all stuff okay
right yeah i know it's a pronoun problem
i don't like it
well you've gotta start speaking that
way and he's gonna con
or or he's never gonna feel connected
and
um in a safe enough place to get well
and at the same time you've got to
protect yourself which sounds like i'm
talking out of both sides of mouth i
hope you can know what i'm talking about
here so here's
here's practical here's what this looks
like in real time
it looks like until you have committed
to sobriety
until you have committed to 30 or 60
days of being completely sober
i'm not giving you access to all of our
money or
all of the pay all of the um the
household finances
i'm gonna i'm willing to step in the gap
here just like
if he got covered and was sick for three
weeks
you would step in the gap and do the
dishes every day right
you would help with the yard right so
whatever other agreements you'll have so
this is the same he's not well he's in a
season where he's not well
and so you are going to take care of the
finances for this season but when he
gets
hurt it's y'alls when he
um doesn't show up to work it hurts
y'all's bottom line
not just his and yeah you can't have
your husband laying in the next room
over here
like with a back injury that needs an
epidural
like well should have saved your money
bro me and the baby are going out for
pizza you can't do that right
i mean you could but we got it taken
care of i know but yeah and i'm speaking
i'm speaking broadly here i'm not just
saying you didn't word that one right
now i just
no i unders but i understand no no no i
mean you hate your husband we hear it um
i'm totally kidding
but it's you're in a mess and the
problem is is you're married to an
addict at the end of the day you're
married to an addict and so you've got
to find a balance between
being connected and being letting them
know he's loved and he's safe
and you've got to take care of that baby
and you got to take care of you
right at some point you have to have the
hard and or conversation i mean the or
if conversation you will get healthy
you will get sober
or i'm going to have to make a dish
other plans
if his behavior hurts that child puts
that child in a position where he's not
safe
puts you in a position where you're not
safe then you're gonna be forced into
making alternative
um arrangements right and that's a scary
scary place to be
i know that you look close to that are
you
yeah okay um have you all gone to see
somebody together
um we've done marriage counseling but
obviously that's the issue that comes up
is what
um is the the root of
well not the complete route but one of
the roots of the problems is that that
part needs to be addressed before you
can have a healthy marriage
that's right and they'll tell you that
in therapy right you both go into
therapists and say hey when you're sober
then we can get to work right
correct have you had a quiet
not angry not loud but a quiet
conversation
that lets him know that you love him and
it feels like you he is choosing alcohol
over you and his
new child oh yeah i've tried to have
that
regularly what's his response
um usually freezes up and won't say a
whole lot
or says hey i used to be drunk seven
days a week and now it's only four and
you need to celebrate it
ana i'm sorry i wish i had better news
for you
me too yeah it sucks
until he decides to make some
significant changes in his life then
it's going to be tough
and what you need to make sure is that
baby is safe and okay
that that baby doesn't grow up in the
home of yelling and screaming
and fighting and lack of accountability
because those traumas imprint on a baby
and they
are there for a lifetime okay correct
and he's my primary concern
our little boy is your little boy safe
yes okay barry okay
well i'd love to talk to your husband if
he'll ever call in he probably won't but
if he did that'd be awesome
nope he won't okay it would be i'd love
it
yeah well i i mean i love him i i'm i'm
sure he's not well and i can almost
guarantee he would
prefer to not be drinking but until he
puts in the work then um
you've got some hard hard decisions to
make moving forward i'm not going to
make those for you
you're going to have to make those other
than if people are safe and
you said y'all are safe um
but until he chooses to get sober um you
can't trust him with the bank accounts
you can't trust him with the jobs you
can't trust him
um to build the future together because
it's just built on wobbly
wet sand and those things collapse and
so on
we'll be thinking about you um
have one more hard conversation with
them okay or two
and uh i'm heartbroken for you i hate
those situations
um addiction just destroys everybody
from with from the addict on down man
oh man if you were struggling with an
addiction
please reach out to somebody that can
help you
four days of being drunk is not better
than seven
if you if you're an addict zero days is
better than seven
and if you're struggling man with
whatever it is with busyness with work
with alcohol with cocaine whatever it is
please reach out the people around you
love you
we love you and i want you to get well i
want you to be able to sleep at night i
want you to be
present with your kid and slowly start
to heal from the inside out